canada will be providing a loan of up to
120 million dollars to the government of
ukraine
russia is aiming to destabilize ukraine
including economically this loan will
help support ukraine's economic
resilience
mr jolie discussed it during her visit
and we're also exploring other options
to provide financial and other supports
i want to thank minister sajin for his
hard work to secure this financial
assistance for ukraine and again
canada calls on russia to de-escalate
and engage in meaningful dialogue
yesterday the russian ambassador to
canada spoke to ctv news and he scoffed
at the idea of sanctions saying that
nobody cares about western sanctions
because they don't work and don't pose a
threat if russia isn't concerned about
sanctions do you think the west needs to
do more than just threaten economic harm
to avoid an invasion in ukraine
we have actually seen uh over the past
number of years that the uh sanctions
that canada and other countries have
brought forward on russia for uh its
unacceptable incursion into crimea and
its continued interference
in the
sovereign affairs of ukraine uh have had
an impact
on russia have had an impact on the
russian people we know
that the russian people do not want to
see
ukraine invaded do not want to see
deaths
in a conflict that should be avoided
that's why we're calling on russia to
de-escalate
calling on diplomatic conversations
but reminding everyone that
we stand with ukrainian people with
their ability to choose
their path forward for their country
and
thrive in the ways that they get
at the pick democratically
thank you for that my follow-up is also
on ukraine there are new reports today
that canada is sending defensive
equipment to boost ukraine's military
capabilities what exactly is canada
sending and how quickly will this
assistance arrive
uh we continue uh to lead in operation
unifier which is a training mission that
canadian armed forces have been engaged
in for a number of years now that i got
to
visit personally in western ukraine a
number of years ago when i uh when i was
in the region um we have always been a
friend to ukraine we will always be
there with the necessary supports
and we look to continue to do that today
we're making a significant announcement
of 120 million dollar loan which is uh
one of the top things that the ukrainian
government has been asking uh for uh
from canada uh the conversations that
our foreign minister had with uh
ukrainian officials including the
ukrainian president stressed that we're
happy to be there to reinforce the
resilience and the strength of ukraine's
economy faced with russian
destabilization including economic
destabilization